violence in Hong Kong is expected to
escalate as China celebrates its seventh
70th anniversary of communist rule
tomorrow clashes erupted again over the
weekend police confirmed the arrests of
more than 150 people
ramie Inocencio is in Hong Kong ramie
good morning this banner behind me
celebrating China's 70th anniversary
along with several others throughout the
city has now been repaired after
demonstrators stormed the central
business district on Sunday angry
demonstrators rips down patriotic
Chinese signs like this one venting
anger against Beijing and what they call
is a slow erosion of their democratic
freedoms on social media videos were
posted of protesters as well as regular
passengers escaping a subway station
closed during the chaos while the
entrance to another was engulfed in
flames sparked by Molotov cocktails the
violence between police and protesters
says
escalated over the past 17 weeks police
now using tear gas and water cannons
loaded with blue dyed liquid a tactic
used to identify protesters all this
while Beijing plans a major celebration
across tenements square where its
military might and economic prowess will
be on full display but here in Hong Kong
protests are planned and that is despite
a police van
those could embarrass Beijing on a day
it wants the world to see China as a
stable and prosperous country Tony
Ramiro since you have for us on the
ground in Hong Kong ramie thank you very
much